[Music]
let's talk about football blue 42 this
football right no no no today we're
talking about this football soccer
no it's football you have the players
the managers and the tea the tea mr
parrish please explain welcome to you
all to nottingham forest fc and have a
great time while you're here and don't
forget if you can try a cup of my tom's
tea
the best
nottingham forest is one of the oldest
football clubs in the world they had a
great run about 40 years ago winning two
european cups and loads of other stuff
no i'm very proud of this team happy
days
but whilst those days are gone there is
still one world-class tradition that
remains well my name is tom parish i'm
almost 89 now not belong before the 90th
i'm a tea boy and i love it people do i
would say teen boy i said yeah work my
way out
[Music]
here in britain it was a common
occurrence for football clubs to have a
tea lady or a tea boy
sadly these traditions are on the
decline but what does a t-boy do oh
cranky what does the t-boy do he makes
tea of course so tom isn't handing out
tea at the sideline he has his own
kitchen next to the team's dressing
rooms let me show you around his job is
to make classic cups of tea for managers
players directors photographers that's
one of our photographers
yes he's a good lad the list goes on
so tom what are your top tips for making
tea you'll get the best tea
and that is
yorkshire tea
boiling water over the tea bag
get it to the side of the cup and
squeeze it as much as you can to get the
juice out of the tea bag put your milk
in that should be i hope
a good cup of tea
[Music]
it's not just a football match it's
something that you look forward to and
it's there every week
that's what keeps you going
and as i said i love it love it as long
as i can walk
and that the club will have me i'll be
here back in a cup of tea
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
racism and xenophobia are unfortunately
everywhere however one woman is turning
this
into this
meet germany's hate destroyer
[Music]
in germany former teacher emelia mensa
sram has made it her life mission to
remove any neo-nazi stickers and
graffiti around her country
it's no easy feat though nein
and how does one arm oneself for a war
against street hate with them currently
or the nagalaki fan or the eve with
foxproof
imel has been covering removing and
obscuring these messages since the 80s
she keeps a record of everything she's
wiped out all
over her country
side written is
[Applause]
and heads off to the streets
sometimes she nails a big one like this
heart
it used to be a swastika
other times it's small but even the
crudest message doesn't slip by
[Music]
my
[Music]
um
[Music]
and as long as there's hate in this
world omela will
[Music]
good
[Music]
it
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
i mean
[Music]
i guess it is pretty green to me it's
not
it wasn't just always all green now i'm
quite green
my name is elizabeth
sweetheart and
i am the green lady
everything is green
i brought green counter and then i got
green knobs and then all the accessories
we even painted the front door green
if i find something that i really like
in terms of clothing and what i wear
i make it green
these are my overalls
i grew up with my family in nova scotia
and they didn't know what to do with me
i wanted to be an artist
i started wearing green when my dad
invited me to visit florida it was
really exciting for me to go because we
hadn't really connected and
he didn't really care for an artist
the water is aqua green deep rich greens
i painted all the palm trees and from
that point on i started adding little
bits of green because it was like a
lucky day that dad asked me to go visit
it's been around 17 to 20 years
i continue to wear green because the way
i dress makes other people smile and say
oh the green lady
[Music]
[Laughter]
can i have a selfie with you
i think people really really like the
belief that you like something enough to
really
carry it through
when you're young you tend to think you
look good in black as you get older you
realize color is so much fun
i will continue to be green because it's
so positive i think when it's not then
i'll change
to my next favorite thing
you